-Welcome back. I'm hanging
with Robert De Niro here.
Now, a lot of people
don't know this,
but we actually
did a movie together.
Remember that?
-No, I don't remember.
-Come on. It was based on
the international best selling
novel, "Space Train."
It was huge. You got to remember
"Space Train," right?
No. Okay.
I have -- I have a clip of it.
Can we -- Can we roll the clip?
-In the not-too-distant future,
a select group of the finest
astronauts humanity has to offer
will be called upon to save
the Earth from cosmic danger.
It just so happens
that they're all afraid to fly.
But for those brave souls,
there is hope.
There is destiny. There is...
space train!
-All aboard.
-Here's my ticket, alright,
but let me tell you
something, alright?
I ain't going to space,
'cause I don't fly, okay?
I would if I could,
but I can't, so I won't.
-Shut your mouth!
This train's about to blast off,
and it's only got one stop.
Outer space.
♪♪
-"Space Train"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think it, uh --
I think it still holds up.
-Yeah, now I remember.